hey everybody my name is rich roll this
is my podcast
welcome to it my guest today is high
performance psychologist dr
michael gervais over the years michael
has worked alongside some of the world's
most accomplished
most elite professional and olympic
athletes
to help them perform at their peak in
high consequence
environments today we pick things up
where we
last left off for basically a
master class on human potential we talk
about mindset
intentional attention and honing focus
in a distracted world and michael drops
incredible
pearls of wisdom on how all of us can
best navigate this complicated time
to find the opportunity amidst the chaos
and grow
if you're digging my stuff and this
channel please take a second to hit that
subscribe button
as well as the little notification bell
so you can be properly
alerted every time we drop a new video i
appreciate you doing that
and i appreciate michael i absolutely
love this guy
truly one of my favorite people so let's
do it this is me
and dr michael gervais
[Music]
dr michael gervais is back in the house
round four
i can't believe it you've changed my
life come on
yeah look what you've built it's
incredible man i'm so proud of you
you're impacting so many lives and
i'm just i'm in i'm in awe of the
quality of content that you put out
and how practical and helpful it is to
so many people and it's been
a delight and a pleasure to watch you oh
man
that means a lot to me i i really i
don't say that lightly that you changed
my life
it was super simple it was benign and
i never would have thought that this
medium this
intimate conversation between two people
would be able to fundamentally shape you
know how i think about
not only humanity but business and
connection with other people and so
that that that afternoon that we sat in
my office
like that changed my life so i
appreciate you brother that's cool
well it was immediately evident to me
and i've said this to you before
that you have a natural gift for this
and that it seemed only only you know
appropriate that you would
launch your own show like you're so good
at it and you have this
like ability to just get right to the
heart of things immediately like you cut
through all the [ __ ]
and you see what other people don't see
and when you listen to your show
you get a glimpse of that and i'm always
like oh man like
because we have a lot of crossover in
our guests so like if i'm preparing for
someone i'm like oh he was on mics i
gotta listen to this like this happened
with
apollo ono recently because he came on
my show and i listened to your
conversation with him and i'm like
i i'm not gonna be able to do that oh
come on that's not even close but you
know
there are some advantages of being a
psychologist
you have a training that i don't have
well you know that being
that being said it there's so much about
just being authentically curious about
the person that's in front of you
and i'll tell you some of the frames i
come from if that's useful mm-hmm
sure unconditional positive regard
podcast tutorial from
from the master no no no no no no no
find some mastery here
okay so unconditional positive regard
for the other
you have that you that's how you've
treated me in
in our first conversation unconditional
positive regard for the other
and i think that as a philosophical note
for how we engage with humans that that
is born out of
the um psychologist and the um
the theory called rogerian psychology
carl rogers
unconditional positive regard and if you
just stay there
i think it ends up paying dividends for
both
yeah i mean i never thought a bit about
it
in that kind of context but
i do like i only have people on that i'm
genuinely curious about
yeah and i've been in situations where a
bunch of people
are like oh you got to have this person
on and i'm not feeling it but i feel
pressured and not pressured but like
well everyone else seems to think this
will be great
and i've learned that if i'm not feeling
it myself
it doesn't mean that they're not a great
guest for somebody's show i'm just not
the right
cipher or host to bring out the best in
that person
oh that's a cool approach yeah and you
know i
i'm curious what you're searching for
right now what is it
look at you
already i'm going to do your show later
man all right let's do that but
just as a high note like what is it that
you're you're going after right now to
try to
better understand hmm well
a couple things i mean the first thing i
would say is i'm starting to put
more attention on
the guests that i'm seeking out because
i really haven't
done that from a vision or
systemic approach it's it's somewhat
reactive
and very much impulsive like i'll just
come across somebody and i'm like oh
they're cool and i'll do that and i
don't
put i don't like put on my calendar okay
i have to book these people and i got to
seek them out and
track them down like it all just kind of
happens organically
and that seemed to work but i think the
show could benefit from
me approaching it from a little bit more
of a mindful
intentional perspective so i'm putting
my focus on that
and also um
most of the conversations that i've had
historically have been
pretty evergreen they stand you know
outside the context of
time and culture i could put them up at
any moment and they would be fine
but the world changed in some pretty
fundamental ways this past year and i
felt called to
participate in that conversation in a
more contemporaneous way
so now every two weeks i'm doing a
conversation with
my friend adam skolnick who co-wrote
david goggins book
and as a new york times contributor
journalist adventurer environmentalist
and we talk about kind of things that
are happening in the now
um so that's new and that's been kind of
a little bit of a
a growth curve getting used to that and
putting myself
out out there in a new and different way
because this has always been about the
guest
but with these particular conversations
that focus gets flipped a little bit
more on me
i've loved it i've loved following what
you're doing yeah that's cool
yeah nice work so yeah that's that's
where my head's at
but you know i i have been spending a
lot of time
paying attention to what's going on in
america and across the world right now
and it's
very unique it's concerning i think
there's opportunity in it as well
so why don't we start with just your
thoughts on on
you know how you feel about what's
what's happening right now and
and how you're thinking about
it from a psychologist's perspective in
terms of how to navigate it in a healthy
way
cool i think that one is let's put a
little
fine point on psychologists for just a
moment
is that there's general psychology you
know and there's child psychology
and then i've cut my teeth in sports
psychology sports performance
and then a sub-specialty if you will in
consequential environments
so if there was such a thing as
high-stakes psychology that would
kind of be where i'd sit so inside of
that
what does that mean my unique experience
is that i've spent
deep time with people that are in the
most consequential
the highest stress environments known to
humans
i'm finding incredible portability right
now from those insights and practices
for the rest of us because we're all in
some form
or another in a in a higher stakes
environment oh
right now the stress levels well if we
just look at some basic data
suicide uh suicide ideation and actual
suicide are up
anxiety depression addiction all curving
you know hockey stick type arc stuff
um so we're seeing mental health and the
echo of mental health is going to be
here for a while the mental health
concerns and the echo
from what's happening right now both
from um
a an awakening from the social injustice
and
and the systemic racism and individual
racism that's taking place
um as well as a illness that we're
struggling
with you know and so
mental health is important and i have
yeah i i don't think i'm the most
i'd like to think i am but i'm not the
most compassionate person
you know i'm more of a systems thinker
and i really
love getting into kind of what the heart
and the truth of something is
and understanding how we can grow and be
authentic in that growth arc towards the
reaches
of what is possible so that that's not
like
i'm not this compassionate um
heartfelt high drive empathetic person
i'd like to be i need to i've been
working on that my whole life
but i'm flooded with it now um right i'm
feeling what people are feeling
and i'm scared you know i'm nervous for
people
and then my friends that are listening
to this right now are saying
dude you're so bullish and optimistic
about the future what are you talking
about
so i've got both of those that are
playing forward right now
so i vacillate i vacillate from
despair to optimism um
and i think on that that scale of
systems thinking to to
you know kind of feeling my way in an
empathetic
fashion i'm more on the empathy side i
could i could benefit from a little bit
more
systems thinking as i just explained to
you and i feel it deeply you know it's
it
and and i feel i've said this before
also but
i'm i'm essentially introverted i'm fine
being alone
you know i like to lock myself up in a
cave and do my thing and i thought
i've been training for this my whole
life man i got this
everyone's going to be out there
suffering and i'm going to thrive
but it's really warm then and not being
able to see your friends and
you know not being able to plan for the
future
or have specific things to look forward
to
is is very difficult but from a personal
perspective the hardest part has been
trying to parent two teenage daughters
through this who
are really having a hard time and it's
been
you know when you say hard time you mean
like mental health mental health yeah
right yeah i've got a extroverted 16
year old who wants to be with her
friends
and is in art school and loves that
tactile
practical aspect of her craft which has
been stripped away from her and now
she's on zoom from eight to four
and then has to do her homework on the
computer all in the home
you know and another thirteen-year-old
daughter who
is very much an introvert but the
deprivation
of external stimuli is causing
you know some real mental strain on her
and i feel powerless to be
of service yeah how to help them figure
this out
i mean i'm just it it just breaks my
heart yeah
i think the fact that you're um aware of
it
is kind of step one because some people
the old model of
let's call it well hold on let me back
up no one's getting through this world
without
facing down trauma big trauma big t or
small t
so suffering is part of the the
experience that we have
it's a shared experience that we have
the word trauma
ends up takes suffering and puts a
little finer point on it
right but what we're talking about is
suffering now
that being said let's call it 1980 model
suck it up harden up figure it out go
back to work
come on what's wrong with you like those
are the messages that we're giving kids
when we were growing up i don't know if
you got those messages but
you know pretty much yeah expl
definitely like the narrative the social
narrative was that whether it was in
in the house or not and right now it's
taken place it's very different the fact
that you're like i'm really concerned
about that
you know right step one awareness
always is going to start there and
whatever practices that we can put in
place
to be able to increase our awareness
we're on to something
step two is be grounded next to the
person that you love
and so i that's what showed up for me
for years working with
some of the best in the world in their
craft and some people that are aspiring
to be
is that when they rattle and i've worked
my ass off to be grounded
that gift whether it's an emotional
rattle or
something else that's taking usually
when we rattle it's emotional
but there's my mentors taught that to me
at a young age
that when i would be melting or
unraveling or frustrated or scared
and this is gary de blasio's my mentor
for a long time
like since i was 16 he just looked at me
because he knew me
and he just looked right into me and
he's like i see you and he's like i'm
here for you
as i'm melting down frustrated scared
whatever trying to find the words to say
that i'm scared but i'm really just
using frustration as the
vehicle the unfortunate vehicle of
talking about fear and sadness
and man just have someone next to you
that sees you and gets you
that in and of itself probably explains
why 70
of treatment effects in small room
psychology
take place from rapport the relationship
in itself accounts for we believe about
of change not the advice or the
counseling
just being there yeah listening seeing
understanding and then if you've got
some really cool tactics and strategies
that you can layer on top of it
that only accounts for 20 to 30
of the change the impulse that i'm
always fighting is
is trying to fix it of course of course
it's like i can't fix it
so then i get rattled and i'm not able
to be
that calm soothing presence
i find that hard to believe it's true
man i fight a heartbeat
julie she'll tell you but you know the
other piece is like but
what you're talking about too is that um
you you did you say the word powerless
or
or helpless which word did you choose i
think i used powerless yeah
which is um that's where it starts to
get scary for the people that are
supposed to be
the powerful right so what does powerful
mean
not like i'm powerful and gonna tell you
what to do
mr mrs you know per like not that type
of power i know that's not what you mean
but albert bandura are you familiar with
his work
ah this is this is gonna be fun rich so
albert bendor dr bandura
um living legend he's uh octogenarian
at this point stanford and he changed
psychology
so uh i like he was one of the
freaking top-tier tip-of-the-error
people that i wanted to have on finding
mastery and
i got to sit down with him so it's like
a living legend that i got to sit down
with
so his uh original paradigm shifting
um theory was on self-efficacy and so
efficacy means power
efficacious it's a beautiful word not
well used
um not often used so self-efficacy
he found that there's five ways to build
a sense of internal power for people to
have
agency and agency is a fancy word for
you determine your experience in life
you're an
agent in this as opposed to
at the whips end of your external world
but so what does it mean to be age
have agency and how do we build efficacy
it's really cool and without getting too
far in the mumbo jumbo you know all of
these skills i'm going to rattle them
all i'll ride them off quickly
vicarious experiences so looking at
somebody
that is doing something close to what
you want to be doing one day
just looking at it and being able to see
that i think i could do that over that's
how
oh look at the choices they made just
watching
mentorship in that way but they don't
have to be true mentors but
something that's close to what you want
to do
what's an example just as an example to
point to to look to
yes yeah that's a so that's actually a
really important part of
becoming efficacious is seeing what
good to you looks like or maybe great
the next is self-talk knowing how to
talk to yourself
you don't know how to talk to yourself
well it's nearly impossible
you know and this is where you recognize
the kind of the [ __ ] of naive
optimism
meets the frontier of being in the
amphitheater
like it's got to be real the way you
speak to yourself
and i haven't met though i haven't met
a world-class thinker or doer that isn't
fundamentally optimistic yeah that's a
key
theme and point that you make time and
time again
and compete to create yeah which i'm on
like chapter eight of now which i love
the audio book yeah yeah the audiobook
it's great thanks i love it yeah um
i love it because it's comprehensive
but it's also very practical and
understandable
and you just relate these tools that we
can all implement into our life that are
all lifted from
your work and your studying and working
with all of these athletes
but what was really striking about it is
is this refrain that all of these things
are are
trainable or teachable from optimism to
grit confidence to calm
we tend to look at high performers and
think well that yeah that guy's super
optimistic he always thinks it's going
to work out
he's able to control his mechanism
he was born that way yeah or had great
parents yeah yeah exactly
and i just you know i'm debbie downer or
i always think it's not going to work
out and that's just the way that i'm
wired
yeah that so there there's likely a
predisposition towards anxiety or
depression
or optimism or pessimism that we're not
fully aware of
right there's some genetic coding that
happens passed on
from a genetic standpoint from our
parents and grandparents that being said
is optimism and pessimism are the two
basic frameworks
for how you view your future it's kind
of that
there's there's not another one some
people might say no
realism well you can have
a realistic pessimism and a realistic
optimism it is the frame that you see
your future through
and so it's a learn it's a trainable
skill
completely trainable so is the opposite
of that
like helplessness and learned
helplessness optimism
and learned optimism oh yeah that that
doesn't actually snap well together
but the optimism and pessimism sorry
both are learned
and which means we can get better at
them so walk me through the difference
between
what you just said and our kind of pop
psychology
version of that like the fake it till
you make it and you know i'm stuart
smalley and i'm going to look in the
mirror and and recount these
affirmations like what's the difference
between truly training somebody
to pivot from you know a pessimistic
outlook on themselves in life
and getting them into a more optimistic
state
okay so the first order of business it's
always going to come down to awareness
like how are you imagining your future
and if it's fundamentally pessimistic
like things don't work out
then let's recognize that there's a
moment to be able to get better at it
you know to shift it
and the data is really strong about why
optimism
is an important function for health
performance
well-being and so the first order of
business like i said is always going to
be awareness
it's where mindfulness and meditation
journaling and conversations with wise
men and women
are really important because if you're
not aware
of the way you're thinking about the
future you can't change it like there's
there's you're kind of stuck but i think
most people are on that kind of
recursive loop where they're not even
consciously aware that they're
constantly affirming some story about
who they are
in it from a negative perspective well
and if you challenge them on it they'll
say
well you don't understand my life or
something like that like there has to be
a willingness or like a crack in that an
opening where they can say or they can
see themselves
from 10 000 feet and say i need to
address this
you're right on the money so this is
this is the unfortunate
insight that i i wish it wasn't i wish
this wasn't the case
but i my experience with working with
people
is that it's not until they have enough
pain do they do the work to change
i'm a living example of that you are
yeah we've talked about that
yeah you really are and my favorite
people are
people that have faced the darkest parts
of being human and
say okay forget about it like i'm going
i'm doing
this differently because they've got to
the truth of some stuff
you know the dark side of humanity the
suffering side and they understand it
and so that being said is like there
needs to be enough pain
for change to happen because change
requires real
work and this is why i'll say to folks
like there's no
hacks there's no tricks and tips you
know for
fundamental growth and it's a mistake to
look at the
strong men and women on the podiums or
the ceos of whatever
and say oh look at how good they are
from a physical standpoint to celebrate
them just because of they've had outward
success is the mistake
the opportunity that sits underneath is
how do they organize their life
and it's a fundamental organization
towards the man or woman or person they
want to become
it's a fundamental commitment and there
are
there are no shortcuts here there's no
hacks to that
so how do we organize our inner life get
real with like the pain
that you are carrying from an early part
of your life
that is still part of the conscious or
non-conscious narrative
that is shaping thoughts and shaping
words that you choose
and shaping the actions that you take
and without some sort of examination
or some sort of honesty about the way
that you shape your thoughts
and your words and your actions i think
it's really tough to
flip a fundamental view of how you think
the future is going to go from pessimism
to optimism
can i add one more layer of complexity
your brain is not trying to help you
become optimistic
the three pounds of tissue is saying hey
dude stay alive
find the threat find the danger you know
you don't want to be
taken for the fool that didn't jump when
there's a a line in the bush
is there lines in bushes you know like
you don't want to be the fool that
doesn't
react properly but you also don't want
to look like the fool that re
reacts too quickly so that's where we
get these freeze mechanisms you know
fight flight freeze and submit
and so your brain is trying to figure
out how to survive and your higher
consciousness you need to probably put a
pin in that because that's a
big word right big phrase but your
your ability to use your imagination
i'll be more pragmatic for a moment
your ability to use your imagination to
imagine what could be for you
counterbalanced to your brain's dictum
to survive to recognize the sources of
threat and pain
real or imagined from early on or or
that's
possibly going to show up in this moment
and it is ready right now to say
hey flood some physiology so that you
can be on point and not be taken
advantage of
in modern times so your brain is not
trying to help you in this
i don't know whether i feel good or bad
about that damn you know so
yeah well i don't think i think that if
we said the good or bad piece and we
said
well that's actually the truth of what's
happening
so what do we want to do about it
fundamental to
all of this in compete to create
is this commitment to self-understanding
like that underlies
all of it like you can relate these
tactics and these strategies like here's
your morning routine here's a breathing
technique
here's a way of journaling and here's a
way of getting clear on what you have
control over versus what you don't have
control over which are all super helpful
but short of a fundamental
commitment to personal growth and
broadened self-understanding these
things are not going to
avail you much right yeah so talk a
little bit about that first
because that's the most important step
like in 12-step
step one is the only one you have to get
perfect i feel like in this context
that commitment has to be firm
for any of these other things to to have
the efficacy
that they potentially can have so okay
so i love so you're getting right to the
truth of it
this is where it all begins is what do
you really want
and if you're looking for
better you know because you know that
there is something deeper in you
there is more room to grow there's
further to go
there's a deeper authenticity there is
deeper purpose and meaning and you want
that in your life
okay so those those are the mechanisms
that i've spent a lot of time trying to
understand
and it has to start from that place like
okay i'm sick and tired
this is a phrase that you'll recognize
of being sick and tired so i'm sick and
tired of
walking into a room and feeling like i'm
just
i'm not grounded i'm not me um i'm
beholden to what they might be thinking
of me
i've abandoned my history for the
approval of
somebody in this room
yeah you like that oh man this is like
my achilles heel
fear of people's opinions oh yeah yeah
it's you're not alone brother
like i suffered i suffered fobo for a
long time it's probably what led me to
you know this this um deep almost
sometimes i don't wish that people have
this um
i don't wanna say maniacal but this and
it's not quite obsessive but it's this
deep kind of want to understand how do
humans work
because i spend i'm up all night
thinking about it it feels like most
nights
you know it's the thing that keeps me
awake it's a beautiful science
it's complicated um but all that being
said
is that's where it starts like is there
more in you
and if there is let me hold on put a pin
in that
there is more in you there is more in me
so
what do we do to be able to free
ourselves up
to express the the reaches of our
potential what do we do
well if you and i wanted to go walk from
here to new york city
and we hadn't done it that walk before
you know what you and i would do we
would go get with somebody we'd say
hey who's walked it tell me what to do
on the rockies
when i get to the rockies tell me what
to do when
you know or help me understand how to
navigate
this type of challenges or what are the
challenges so you would go
get around a community of people that
understand deeper
that have done it they've traveled the
path and that would be
the second step is there more yeah
but that example presupposes that you
have enough self-understanding to know
that you want to walk from
california to new york i feel like
there's a lot of people who are living
their lives reactively
they know they want their they thirst
they hunger for more meaning more
purpose more passion in their life
but they're completely bereft of the
tools
or the means by which to connect with
what that might look like
so they're shooting darts in the dark
thinking
i want these things but how do i even
begin the process of trying to figure
out what that might mean for me
so i would say um the way that we do it
for
let's just talk individually right now
for one-on-one type stuff
is let's say let's use an extreme
example somebody's really struggling
right and they're highly anxious or
highly depressed or they're really
struggling in in life
first it's like okay well let's let's
just stabilize a little bit
and so stabilizing is like how do we
help somebody be present
and being present is where your body and
your mind
are in the same place focusing on the
same thing
so that's what being present is so how
do we do that
first and if you're not with somebody
that knows how to do that how do you do
that
well this is where meditation and
mindfulness is like
the modern science and the ancient
wisdom of it is paying dividends it's
one of the ways to start
and if that feels like too big like
focusing on one breath at a time
over and over and over again if that
feels too big then
okay how do we get to that next place
well maybe there are some
very easy ways to say okay well i'm
going to start being my best
coach and so now we're kind of moving
into that self-talk thing a little bit
and the small band-aid kind of tactic if
you will
is be great at coaching yourself today
mindfulness is about listening and then
coaching is
more about self-talk like what are you
going to say to yourself so those are
two kind of maybe some ways to
start and then i'd say [ __ ] get your
sleep right
yeah you know that's super practical you
got your whoop on
oh yeah yeah i i've been i i see you've
got yourself never i haven't taken it
off since i got it
seriously i love it yeah yeah can i tell
you a funny story
yeah so i i first got it
when i was doing this is your world that
i played in for a moment
but it was an ultra that i was training
for i followed it oh dude
i met i met somebody i met myself in a
different way
i i can't wait to tell me about that
yeah so you were you were in a paddle
board from catalina to
l.a stand up yeah so stand-up paddle
i grew up as a kid surfing and i'd look
as i look west there's an
uh an island catalina island it's about
30 miles away
and i get frustrated with the island
because it would block some of the big
south swells that would come in
and then also i'm incredibly inspired by
the island from this one narrative
which was natives that long ago that
were on the island
would build their own canoes and
they'd pair up either two people or
three people or sometimes one person
they would travel the 30 miles come grab
some supplies
and then bring it back to their family
i'm like damn that's
yeah it's legit it's across shark alley
it's across
you know 30 miles of open ocean there's
some pretty
uh shifty currents that are happening in
the pacific and i always thought like
you know hundreds of years ago that was
taking place like man i'm equally as
inspired this is weird but
the men and women that put up phone
wires or phone poles
in the as pioneers to places like deep
and mountains and
i'm always like somebody was here
drilling into you know
mother earth here oh i don't know why
but anyways
so i'm watching that and then one of my
friends i shared that
idea with him like how inspiring he goes
why don't you do it
i don't know i don't i don't do ultra
types i don't do
distant stuff i'm not built for that
and so he just self-defeatism coming
right out of the gate for
a high performance psychologist i
thought it was actually working from
reality
yeah but i was like i didn't think i had
that
and i had very little interest you're
watermen though yeah i spent a lot of
time in the water
but not but but if you think about the
way i've organized my life it's really
more about um in the sport world and
working with the athletes i work with
more about intense adrenaline management
um and then it wasn't until maybe about
eight years ago that i started started
spending time with people that were
doing
back to back stuff like what you're
doing you know like really
distance-based stuff
um carl metzner d metzler metzler
do you know that name he ran the pony
express no so it's a project that we did
with red bull
metsker metzger i think it's metscare
yeah
it sounds familiar it was amazing he ran
the pony express
sorry carl if you're listening i'm sorry
carl yeah it was a um
it was amazing what he did he ran the
pony express like almost without
stopping like back to back you know days
like
it was incredible so that's when i first
really got exposed to the red bull
project
of what it takes for you guys to do what
you do so a friend of mine held me
accountable
and um i said yeah okay at one point i
was like
yeah yeah i could i think i could
imagine myself doing that
and for two three years in a row when
the season would arrive he's like so are
you gonna train for it
ah maybe next time you know and finally
it's like enough of your [ __ ]
and so we were training and um
i blew it on nutrition dude i took
everything so seriously i
and i want to get to the woop story but
i didn't i never did anything like this
and i got my nutrition wrong
so a mile 23 of 31
um i was hallucinating and it also
happened to be
that i was doing 3.1 miles an hour
uh into a 3.1 mile current
so standing still at for 47 minutes
um hallucinating mild hallucinations
just under under fueled
um yeah i mean overtaxed under fueled
i came out classic rookie mistake i came
out too fast
and everyone told me mike take your time
come out slow and
and i thought i was um but i didn't
really have
this the awareness and sophistication i
didn't have someone coaching me you know
from a distance to do
like slow down that just comes with
experience though i mean it being your
first
you you bit off something big for your
first time out
yeah and this is the fun part about the
whoop
i'll go in reverse order i met myself in
a new way at mile 23.
and i needed it you know i felt
disconnected to nature so i called this
thing called i
called the project project reconnect and
what i learned
twofolds was like what isolation and
loneliness means
uh because i was there i felt a sense of
abandonment that i was
like i don't know why but abandonment
came up for me which was a
really cool way for me to get to some
truths for me
and then the second thing is that um i
realize that i am nature
we are nature so nature is not the ocean
that i would go get connected to
you and i are the same kind of stuff
and so it was a recalibration that
i didn't need to reconnect to nature i
need to reconnect to my nature
and we are nature it's not the mountains
and the oceans the in the grass
our humanity is nature and it's
complicated it's beautiful
so that was uh kind of what happened it
was transformative say at least for me
and then
but whoop back to woo so
one of the peter park was a man who was
helping me get right get fit
and he's amazing i don't know if you
know peter but i know who he is i've
never met him
yeah and so amazing human you guys would
love the conversations uh that you guys
would have but anyways so he's helped me
get right
and he goes listen make a promise when
you wake up in the morning it was like a
4 30 wake-up call he says
don't check your whoop who gives a [ __ ]
yeah
you're going right i was like yeah so
i'm going
so um long story made a little bit
longer here is that
i wake up in the morning and we had to
move up our launch date it was just a
strike mission it was just me
going uh with a boat in case i got in
trouble a trail boat
and um and so
uh oh so we had to move up the date a
week early
and so i had i had five days of travel
in
um like seven different hotel rooms and
i was like okay give me a two day
breather and
then no gotta go now
so so i woke up and you know what my
whoop score was
i don't know 13. yup was it it was 13
oh man i've had those days i'm going to
show you i'm going to pull it up and
show you
wake up and you're just like today is
not my day so it becomes a predictor of
behavior
so it's dangerous in that regard so i
didn't look though yeah
i made the commitment and so that had
something to do with bunking
like i was on fumes and you know it also
reminds
me of and i think you know this probably
better than i do is that
we are made of so much we are capable of
so much
and so um there's so much more inside of
us and so it was a reminder of that
yeah that's great i love that i mean i
think that there's
it's beautifully told um and i'm glad
you have that experience i think there's
something
very unique about the endurance pursuit
that stands
distinct from the acute challenges of
some of the athletes that you work with
where it's about these like
microscopic moments yeah and that kind
of you know
and and dealing with like fear you have
you know guys jumping out of planes at
000 feet and the kind of stuff that that
you're more familiar with but wait
without a parachute right without a
parachute into a 16 story net
that he built did you have luke on the
show no i i would love to
oh i would love to you guys would have a
great conversation yeah i'd love to talk
to that guy
insane for people that don't know
michael worked with luke akins who
jumped out of a plane at 25 000 feet
without a parachute and landed in a net
this is the most bananas thing ever
the size of a two-car four-car garage
you know like he's working with uh
with david blaine right now are you
involved in the ascension project
i'm not no when i saw david do his
little trailer
uh i i immediately thought of you and
wondered whether you were involved
yeah luke is yeah luke that's a that's a
pretty luke's is more dangerous i think
by far
but what david blaine's doing is real so
it's supposed to be like today i think
but weather pushed it off so
basically what he's doing for those that
don't know and he will have done it
by the time this airs but he wants to
just
strap himself to a whole bunch of
balloons and float up into the air like
a little kid
yeah you know and he and he has a
parachute up in the balloons but he's
not going to put it on until he's out of
sight because he wants that visual
and then his his idea is to go up to
the elevation of everest he wants to get
above 25 000
hopefully up to 29 and then parachute
down
it's crazy it's awesome what's so
amazing and unique about that guy
is that he pairs his
magic skills with these true feats of
athletic endurance that's right the
breathing and the cold and all the stuff
that he does that makes him very
special yeah for sure but back to the
endurance thing i mean i think
what i've learned and what it sounds
like you got a taste of is
is that unique experience of
self-connection
that occurs when you're beyond depleted
and stripped of all of your natural
defenses
and all the layers that prevent you
from being that connected to who you are
and the environment and there's
like a percolation of self-awareness and
self-understanding that occurs
and then it translates into doing these
things that you didn't think you were
capable of and so you become more
connected to your
potential like the ceiling on what you
become
what you believe is possible gets raised
that's exactly it and you were asking
earlier like how do people
actually get to step one maybe the step
is to sign up for something with you
because you're going to push them into
the like you know into that thin herd
space
you know and i don't know if you're
doing that much anymore with
the current conditions or at all but if
if somebody could pair up with you for a
little bit
i mean you'll take them there oh i could
take them there
yeah you'll take them there and and what
a guide you'd be
really you know and so that's one way to
do it for sure and
i also think that we don't have to do
extreme anything
to get to the extreme awareness you can
do it on a pillow
you can do it in a conversation with
someone that is wise
and you can do it by yourself in journal
it's harder that way
it's harder yeah you know or you could
take ayahuasca i suppose
which some people do yeah um we all have
our
our ways of getting there i guess yeah
yeah that's come
but yeah but endurance soldier endurance
has been this amazing
teacher in my life and i don't
necessarily feel like i have that much
more that i feel like i need to prove to
myself in that regard
but the lessons that i've learned from
that inform everything that i do
there you go and you know i think that
right now the lessons that we need to
learn
are incredible right now like whole like
what are we doing with politics
you know what what are we doing with
covid
and what are we doing with i mean this
the
perfect storm here between racial
justice
um mother nature like
let me let me speak on mother nature for
just a minute one more minute is that
i bought this i'm i'm disappointed it's
too strong of a word but
man i bought this sinker this hook
is a better way to think about it early
when covid was first announced
and it was like okay isolation lock down
war you know front lines
home front and then i said wait a minute
those are all jail house terms
those are all like war-based frameworks
that we're trying to do something
against mother nature
so it's wrong our our tactic
our approach is fundamentally dislocated
from how mother nature and we are mother
nature are working together
and so i think that if we could take a
pause
and this is not practical but as an at
an individual level
right to take a pause and say what is my
relationship with nature
and not to get too woo-woo about
anything but this is mother
nature speaking to us this is our planet
saying hey
i got something they're going to spin at
you here and what is your relationship
going to be with it and
all that being said is like i've bubbled
up big time you know like i've
uh for part of my job responsibilities
and to honor the people that i work with
like
in a really significant way so but i
just want to pause and say
let's get back to maybe some first
principles about nature
and how we're relating to our nature and
the nature around us
there's a lot to be mind in that i mean
similar to you
i've been essentially locked down but
i've spent a lot of time
thinking about that you know not just
the efficacy of
our national strategy or global strategy
but how to behave on a personal level
like there's
there's our macro relationship with
nature
and then our interpersonal relation each
one of our individual
relationship with nature on a macro
level nature is telling us
look your your systems are broken your
relationship with the animal kingdom
is what created this so i'm going to
throw you a curveball
because you need to take a look at this
we're not really taking a look at it
on an individual level there's very
little talk about
ensuring that our individual immune
systems are intact and part of
buttressing our immune system is being
in contact
with a diversity of environments
and other people but now we're being
told we have to
remove ourselves from other people and i
understand that like and i'm doing that
and i'm wearing masks and being a good
citizen and all of that
but what is really going on here and now
we're in this situation where we bungled
and mishandled this to such a vast
degree
that there's no end in sight for
this current protocol short of a vaccine
being developed
we're just going to continue to
accumulate a thousand cases a day
or whatever it is uh we're not going to
reach hurt immunity
in this way we're we're kind of either
we completely lock down or we
completely open up but we're in this
liminal space where
we're not really achieving anything
except prolonging the length at which we
have to
delay everything else in our lives
yeah i'm it's um
you and i are going to be fine and we're
going to figure it out because we have
agency back to kind of point number one
and we are using
as best we can our community and our
information from science and our history
and being alive to want to do right you
know
for self and others and
those that have some underlying
conditions some real anxiety some
victimization some um some depression
like holy [ __ ] like really you can't go
out of your house right now
you know without being scared or there's
a belligerence that you
hide behind like i'm not doing this you
know but that's an over
course over correction too for many
people at least
for um a trigger point or
a tripwire for what it feels like to be
told what to do
and so i'm yeah
it's brutal well it's a witch's brew
it's not just the pandemic
it's our political environment it is
economic insecurity that's driving
you know fear division vitriol
loneliness separation there's a giant
swath of
this country who feels unheard they feel
like they lack agency in their lives and
now
they're we're in a situation that's so
acute that it's a trip wire
so we're seeing these flare-ups you know
and then they end up in these videos
they get shared on social media
that is only exacerbating this vicious
cycle of
of acrimony that is denigrating
the the kind of cohesiveness of the
american experiment in general
it's crazy i've never seen anything like
this meanwhile
you know we have these um
uh you know social protests over
police brutality and racial injustices
and all of those are you know to some
degree appropriate responses to
you know a system that has perpetrated
harm and
um and lack of justice for so many
people
in this country and all of that taken
together has created this moment
that is very strange and it's cr from
for myself it's like there's an
uncertainty like how do i
engage with the world right now and i
find myself at times like should i say
this
well if i say this then that person's
you know like the people are like
afraid to speak they're afraid to act
um we don't know what the ground rules
are
here and it's unprecedented in certain
ways yeah i think
i i know i struggle with that same thing
like this this bit of a dance if you
will
because um but here's how i sort it out
and the dance is like how can i say this
or that
right and speak my truth and also
um not alienate people that i might make
a mistake
in what i'm trying to sort out because
i'm a learner i'm trying to figure this
out with everyone else
and i've got to get back to first
principles is what i do
so what are my first principles that
matter most to me and i've got and
my first principles might not be your
first principles but if we can get back
to
first principles those kind of guiding
principles that
shape in the most aspirational way
your thoughts your words and your
actions and if if we can take a moment
to re-examine those
and when i do that i am so clear
for me um and this i'm gonna say
something that's
charging and electric i'm not voting for
somebody that doesn't care about
humanity
and when i say that i know that people
are saying well what do you mean
he of course donald trump you know is is
about humanity
i can't see it so i'm not voting that
way there's no chance that i'm voting
that way
you know if i had a daughter which i
don't i'd feel awful
and i might be offending you in the way
that because i don't know your vote and
it's okay if you don't want to share
sending me yeah i don't know i don't
know where you're
with you on that and so i've got to get
back to
first principles for me and what happens
for many people is they go
let's say that there's somebody at our
table that goes well i got first
principles too
and my first principles line up with
supporting um
donald trump for president and so now
where we find ourselves in a problem is
because they're so foundational and
fundamental
that we feel like we've got to protect
them those first principles
and so now we're in a vicious
protection aggressive you know it feels
like it's
a survival mechanism and a war that's
taking place
on first principles and i that's where
we are right now
and so so for me um another first
principle
is to create space to talk and to
dialogue and to be curious
and at the same time have an eye and a
lens on humanity
if we don't have that i'm really not
interested in being in the conversation
and so i'm finding myself removing
myself from
many layers of conversations with people
because i know that their first
principle
is so orthogonal and there's not an
interest
in anything other than defending first
principle as opposed to exploring
i'm okay to be wrong i'd say my ego is
no longer
involved in what i do and if my first
principles and the way i'm acting on
them are in
error which they will be at some points
in my life
cool call me out i want to be i want to
get better
but a first principle for me sorry to
get on the soapbox with you but
humanity like it's the first principle
humanity
empathy listening conversation
nuance appreciation
yeah not narcissism i know what that is
as a trained psychologist and i'm not
diagnosing anybody
but you know what when you can't see
another person and really
separate that another person is
different
than your identity think about that for
a minute
that's what narcissism is the inability
to know the difference that you are your
own individual person and not merely a
reflection
of me that is a disordered way
of engaging socially and so what happens
when people
can't see that you have your own life
and your own experience
that you're merely a reflection of me
and if you're right now you're wearing a
striped shirt and i don't like striped
shirts
i'm gonna be cunning and sophisticated
and making you feel
absolutely horrible about how dare you
wear
how stupid are you why would you wear a
striped shirt
like please striped shirts what is wrong
with you
and now to the point where at some point
you're like oh maybe i should
maybe i should change but i've just
berated you because i got the fopo
yeah but i just berated you as opposed
to like going to saying
hey that's really curious striped shirts
what's up with that
so i don't know crazy got me going
no i like it i appreciate that yeah you
fired up a little bit
yeah i mean i think that us
us folks that care about humanity and
the planet need to vote
in an aggressive way and come out you
know make
get the get the mailing thing right
whatever whatever
you're capable of doing in north america
right now
um man be bold i appreciated
your co-collaborator pete carroll's
words the other day how about social
justice how about it
i mean he he's been about this for a
long time yeah you know and so
uh which part of his message just the
speech that he gave in general about
like
look man we you know this is this is
real and we got to deal with this
like it feels on some on some level it's
like
of course but when you contextualize
that
within the the culture of of the nfl
and how they've conducted themselves you
know over the course of this
you know crisis that we've endured um it
feels bolder than it should
yeah you know
it's complicated and i'm so mindful that
um i've got i've had incredible
privilege in my life
and not from an economic standpoint i
didn't i wasn't born with a silver spoon
but the privilege and the advantage that
i've had
is um a gift that i didn't even ask for
but i got it and so the first time i
heard white privilege
i was like get out of here you don't
know where i came from like
no one from my family came i had a
college education
you know i had we had a well on a farm
that we came from
we didn't have uh our pipes were kind of
busted up but we
you know we had to figure stuff out as a
kid you know i still had nice things
you know i didn't go without and i was
like get out of here like no chance that
i come from a privileged
what you think is privilege and then
this was like four or five years ago
when that word was first
introduced to me and the gift that i've
received from some of the players at the
seattle seahawks and the rich
conversations we'd have
on the bus in between you know practice
and
on on road trips in between practice and
uh
and games and whatever and when they
broke it down
to you have an advantage
strip that word away privilege you have
an advantage you call the cops if
something's wrong with your home right
yeah not us
you know go fill in the blanks keep
going right down the list and so i go oh
i had an advantage
yeah i i see that and um i want to be
careful because
i've had lots of advantages but it can
also sound like i'm starting to get
egotistical and some of the the things
you know but
the basic advantage of just being uh
born into a system that values white
and being caucasian that's that's um
that's something to pay attention to
yeah
well i just love that that coach carol
addressed it directly
yeah he did yeah yeah i think that um
he's a humanist period you know he
studied
humanistic psychology he did is one of
his degrees
um his his master's degree studied one
of the uh
humanistic psychologists and how it
impacts i didn't know that yeah so he's
a humanist as well um
how are the seahawks doing well we don't
know you're going you're going up to the
bubble soon
well you know the bubble is pretty
intense and
um we got to figure out what the right
rhythms are and so one of the reasons
i've been bubbled up is to make sure
that i'm doing the right thing
if ever you know that but this is it's a
dislocating experience for me this year
and so i typically i travel from la to
seattle
every week for two three four times or
days a week
um but to come to do that this year is
irresponsible
yeah you know and so yeah so the
season's about ready to
fire up mm-hmm uh pre-season's happening
here in a bit
and i'm not sure at the time of the
recording where we'll be but what a
massive experiment yeah you know that's
taking place right now
what's your perspective on how the nba
has handled it
meaning uh full-on bubble up right yeah
um
i think that at the time i would say i'd
make that same decision
you know and i'd probably still stay the
course
you know there's great consequences to
this consequences to family
consequences to uh earnings for the
league
um it feels responsible so
uh there's there's there's pro cons to
both
but uh i'd feel safer in that
environment than some of the other
environments that yeah i see taking
place
i was watching uh um matisse tables
vlogs on youtube did you check those out
no i didn't but i heard it
yeah it was great you know you're like
you just get this flavor of what the day
to day
like mundanity is and all the protocols
that are in place and how they really it
really is a bubble like they're just
in their hotel rooms and you know
getting tested and going to practice
and living completely isolated you know
in this
weird experiment and this is in many
respects
is a there's something really important
for all of us to say what is the purpose
of sport
in society is it a luxury is it a
requirement
how does it fit why are we so interested
in making this is it a business
like where does sport in modern day fit
in our narrative you know because
i can see parents making what i would
consider risky decisions putting their
kids back into sport
unmasked with lots of other kids running
around and i'm talking about like
four 13 14 year olds which is not the
you know they're
super spreaders in many respects so um
i'm not doing that with you know in my
family but
so where does sport sit and i think
it's a great question yeah i mean how do
you answer that for yourself
well i think it's um entertainment first
i think that fitness and health is
different you know as
a as a component but it's at this point
modern sport is entertainment that's
actually how they're classified their
paychecks are classified
and so um it's a way of living for
people
it's their life it's their passion but
from a social standpoint
it's entertainment and that
entertainment is a business i mean it's
is
is it not business concerns that are
driving this push
to get it rolling oh for sure so like
yeah for sure and
i think also when you when you when you
look at the kind of the
the picture of any league right now
there's definitely business drivers
and when you think about the importance
of business across our country
and these pockets it's really important
to many you know it's opening a lot of
doors
in communities and then when you drill
down the next level
um coaches you know what happens to a
coach if there's no
yeah what happens to the athlete's
paycheck you know that's
what happens to the you know the
equipment folks and the ticket
folks and so it's a it's a larger issue
about
um health and if they can get it right
from a protective standpoint
okay you know but there's
i think sometimes we forget just how
just because they're
on tv and they're highly skilled they
deal with the same
exact stuff you and i do maybe even
amplified yeah
they're no different than the two of us
how are your olympic athletes that you
work with
dealing with everything that's happening
right now i mean i just can't
fathom having that dream pulled out from
underneath me
when your whole life is oriented towards
working
towards that specific moment and then it
becomes unavailable
yeah it's happening in college right now
too yeah college football
college like stanford volleyball imagine
being one of the best in the world going
into stanford
and now the program's you know shut down
like what it's unbelievable i mean
stanford volleyball is like
the fact that it's crazy dominant
dominant you know and so it's happening
at the olympic level the pro level it's
happening
at the college level and even in high
school for sure you know senior year
uh the hot recruit and now this kind of
hodgepodge thing that's
taken across the country so it that's
but
here's here's two examples that's
happening at the olympics to go back up
to your question
one athlete said this is awesome mike
and this athlete is a absolute
flat out world leader in the sport their
sport
i'll keep gender and sport out of it for
obvious reasons
this is awesome i get to repair
i get time i need time on my side and
this is this could i hope it sure i sure
hope it happens
but i think i was probably going to make
the team because to make most of the
teams
in the united states means that you're
one of the best in the world
and trials as you recognize is
oftentimes a higher hurdle
than the actual games correct and so i'm
pretty sure i was going to make the team
but
whoo i got some time now well it depends
on the individual because for the person
who's coming up
who's maybe a little bit on the younger
side the little less experienced side
this definitely plays to their advantage
but for the person who's hanging on
and this is their last dance one more
year
i don't know if i can do it especially
when you're just trying to like
put ramen in the bowl at night like most
of these people
they they you know there's this myth
that
they're all supported and have these
sponsors and that's true for only a very
few people
most this is old data but i think it's
it's about six years old
that the majority of athletes or the
average uh for the united states that go
into the games that make it to the games
are 150 000 in debt by the time they
show up at the games crazy
yeah and you know what we do we're
celebrating you know we're watching on
tv and we're like feeling so good about
america
and that aspirational all-in beauty
uh that they represent of us like
they're coming back and if they don't
have a medal
they're yeah you know did you see uh
the way to go that hbo documentary i
haven't seen it yet
but yeah it's all about that yep whether
you're
atop the podium or an also ran once that
sun is set on that event
and you're overnight back to civilian
life
that transition is rough and i'm sure
you deal with that a lot with the
athletes that you work with
transitions are really hard we're in a
massive transition right now
you know all of us are in transitional
phase right now but transitions out of
sport which you
well recognize is really tricky and so
that being said there are some
frameworks to help through transition
um north stars realigning the north star
realigning
purpose and life is kind of where it
starts and so
right now for all of us that's there is
a moment right now for all of us to say
okay what's my north star
what does north star mean purpose what
is my purpose
and so that's a big conversation that i
have
with folks um touching
a touchstone on a regular basis okay
let's go back to purpose
and i found that most people don't know
their purpose they can't articulate it
because it feels so big it feels like
well how do you
know your purpose aren't those people
that have purpose the lucky ones
and they just kind of knew early on i
don't have purpose
my purpose is for my family well that's
purpose now
so if purpose there's three components
to purpose
it's got to matter to you alone have
meaning to you
the second is it is bigger than you
and the third it's future oriented so as
you're trying to articulate what is my
purpose in life
it just needs those three factors and
then if that feels too big
you can say well what is my purpose for
this month
you can thin slice purpose you can then
slice it all the way down to what's my
purpose today
and if you did a bunch of those in a row
you probably snap up to larger purpose
and so you can then slice it it's not in
that
in that framework it seems digestible
what's the difference between purpose
and vision like in compete to create you
talk a lot about vision like you need to
have this vision this
this idea of what you want your life to
look like and you have to put
intentional attention on developing that
and that's challenging to me because i
don't know that i've really
thought that through very much for
myself we can talk about that later but
how do you distinguish purpose from
vision are those
similar are they two different things
yeah this is where
like language is really important and so
vision is really about when you use your
imagination
and you think about what it's like to be
you or it's like or what the environment
that you want to co-create
to be but if we just talk about you for
a minute when you close your eyes and
use your imagination
what is the vision that you can create
about
your best you know like what does it
look and feel like
and so that's what that is about what's
the vision of your
potential whatever word we want to use
that when i say those words out loud
like your best and potential it feels so
the language doesn't do it quite right
because it seems
right yeah geoistic yeah that's right
but it really is the mechanism that's
underneath when you close your eyes and
create an imagination
of what could be what you would like
your future to be
that's what vision is about purpose
is the why that sits underneath it like
what what is your life purpose
and the vision imagination is what does
that look and feel like
when that purpose is um
is aligned with the man or woman or
person you want to be
um does that help mm-hmm and then
underneath that is like mission like
little missions
like little missions it still feels
esoteric like trying to figure out how
to drill that down
into you know a practical application on
a day-to-day basis
and then let's complicate it because
then you got like what's your philosophy
all right right yeah i got to have a
purpose a vision and a philosophy
come on come on man you need all of them
you know i got [ __ ] to do
but that's right i gotta pay some bills
too you know like yes
but so purpose is this thing like what
am i doing with my time here
vision is what does it look like when
it's firing on all cylinders
and then philosophy is what are the
guiding principles
you know is love a guiding principle
that is important to you is
kill or be killed a guiding principle is
um capitalism at all cost you know
winner go home
or is it you know something on the other
side which is like
uh cooperation is it um
uh i'm blanking on like different
principles that that matter but so
principles
that's your philosophy vision is what
does it mean when you use your
imagination
go big figure it out like not the what
but the how
and then what about values because
that's come up on the podcast a lot like
aligning your actions with your what is
your value system and are you aligning
your actions
with that value system it's cool that's
those are principles values are
principles
values in action are really first
yeah and so i would not separate those
two
seems like a lot of work does it yeah
okay hold on when you use your
imagination
and you think about here you go you're
turning it on me you want to wait for it
away from our pocket one way for the
other one okay well i'll indulge you a
little bit yeah
so when you use your imagination and you
think about what it's like
to be you when you're like
just at your best what's that what's
that about
what are the words you use what are the
images that come up
effortless uh strong
capable articulate
and then what are you doing to express
those
characteristics like when now we're
using imagination about
what's possible in your life so it's
about you being that
way but then what do you think that is
is it
um let's do sport for a minute is it
like
i don't know being in the super bowl is
it breaking records
is it you know there's some concreteness
now to get into
is it building a media empire for you is
it um
you know being like absolutely a
community-minded person
like when you when you go there what is
how does it start to create some texture
or some shape
yeah i i think that and maybe we could
talk about this more on your show but
i look at like let's just take this
podcast for example so
i approach this much like i would
approach a race i trained as a swimmer
as a kid i learned visualization
techniques
i learned how to train my body and my
mind to prepare for
an event and i carry those tools into
everything that i do
so today i show up i prepare
so that i'm ready i get in the right
frame of mind and mindset
i try to make sure i get enough sleep
and that i'm nourished and all of those
things
so that i can show up and
be the best version of myself in this
conversation
the goal being to have the the most
present authentic
best version of what this conversation
could possibly be
in the same way that when i would get up
on the blocks for a swimming race
i visualized it so much that now it's
just a matter of
executing right it's different in that
in a swimming race there's much more
that you have control over
there's fewer variables i don't know
what you're thinking what you're going
to say
okay this is great and i have to just be
present
and available for whatever is going to
happen
and not try to control it so there's a
there's a relinquishing
in it but i don't think about like oh
i'm going to build this huge media
company or
i want to influence this many people
like i just try to i'm much more
in the moment of i i trust and believe
that
if i repeatedly show up with
the best version of who i can possibly
be that those other things kind of
take care of themselves okay so
awesome you've got the the frameworks
and the process
to show up and be your very best you
know that flat out
you know how to do that yeah i've been
doing that my whole life that's right so
that's
baked and that's where you just went in
this conversation so then
i if we were if you and i were kind of
drilling down which we can we can do
later this will be fun
but if we're drilling down i'd say okay
so you know what
here's a vision that somebody said let's
get the best racers in the world
together
uh swimmers and let
let's see who actually excels let's see
who can actually
peak and prime and bring it amongst the
best
that's a vision and then then if that
person
if that person was you you were creating
that vision for swimming
okay and then i would double click about
the vision for you and say
what what is it like for you when you're
building towards that vision
and you're like oh i want to be free
what were the words used there's an
effortlessness to the way that i would
work
and so that's starting to shape a vision
okay
then i would say well what's the purpose
of this why do this
why create this vision for your life
what you
what it is that you're creating but who
the man that you want to become
through this exercise what's the purpose
and then you have to answer that
right and then i'd say you could use
values but i'd say what are your what
are your guiding principles
because you're gonna have to make lots
of choices and then when you're making
those choices
you know to be a savage in business or
to be a
collaborator whatever being orthogonal
you got to make these micro decisions
the better you know your principles the
easier you can line up your thoughts
words and actions
right and then you'll be your best
so i'll do this with you just super
practical my purpose is to help people
live in the present moment more often
that's it that's my purpose in life is
to help people
live in this moment more often and what
i know
is that to do that we have to condition
and train our minds it's very specific
i love that i i would have thought you
would have said something like i wanna i
want to help people
achieve their potential or i want people
to i want to help people
uh you know unlock their most authentic
self or their best self
i think that's cool you know but those
are broader yeah
that's specific yeah for me because
those things occur as a result of being
more present in your life
yeah yeah so what my purpose and
remember when we go back to the science
is that there needs to be three
components it needs to matter to you
uh yes i want people to like be their
very best whatever but you know what
i want to help people understand because
this is the key hole
living in the present moment and knowing
how to condition and train your mind so
that you can be present more often
across potentially any condition that
you are gonna find yourself in
[ __ ] that's the key hole for me that's
what gets my hair to stand up because i
know what's possible
for people when they invest in the inner
life and
and so so then the next is what's the
vision
the vision is a community of people that
are flat out flourishing
right and so i want to be part of that
community i want to curate that
community
that's actually what we have in the
finding mastery community right now
and so because they're investing in
their mind
and training their mind and organizing
their inner life so we're creating a
community of flourishing
and that becomes this exponential what
happens if you've got a bunch of people
that are
like really thriving in the right way
i don't know yet my imagination hasn't
gone there yet i i i wish that i could
get there i don't have that yet
and then i've got first principles that
are guiding my choices guiding my words
and my thoughts and my actions
so i can be about it um in any
moment of test there's a lot of clarity
there
how long did it take you to arrive at
this oh i've been chipping away
chipping away chipping away my mentor
what's it really about mike what are you
really doing chipping away chipping away
every time i read i bounce it up against
am i full of [ __ ] is this right
you know like so it's a work in progress
it's um it's part of the ecosystem of my
inner life that i'm
bouncing up against those and i'm
reserving the right
rich to change it too yeah you know like
but it's been
but this is what you take to these
corporations when you and coach carroll
consult right you talk about this in the
book like working with microsoft and
these companies where you get people to
really drill down on
on these things for themselves yeah so
we this is a cool story this is i'm able
to talk about this
is that it's in page four five six of
satya nadella's book hit refresh and so
satya is the ceo of microsoft
so we're doing a bunch i was doing a
bunch of work with satya and his
executive leadership team and it's an
eight hour training
and subsequently we've trained about 30
to 40 000 people
across their organization at eight hours
a person on how to train their mind
think about that investment oh my
goodness
that's a real investment so we that's
why we built this online course
and the book is meant to be a tandem to
it but that's why we built this online
course and that's the real
mechanism i think to help align my
purpose
is it's an eight-hour training to show
you how to condition your mind in the
practices
and a community of people that are doing
it together so we got to the place where
we talked about philosophy
and satya had a moment and he's
i don't know maybe six months into the
job and he
uh 17 15 or so direct reports
180 000 employees roll up to these
15 16 people multi-billion dollar
corporation and he pauses he checks the
room and he says
our mission is real and it's big
and we're trying to do something amazing
and so
what i want to do is i want to know you
i want you
to know each other i want you to know me
and so let's spend
whatever amount of time we need right
here to get our philosophies
our true philosophies in line and then
share them with each other
amazing moment yeah that's pretty cool
yeah so
running a massive organization like
coach carroll running the seahawks right
like creating a culture of openness and
transparency
where if you can get everybody on the
same page and
align then you become unstoppable and
what we found is like a 30 30 30.
so 30 in a so culture what is culture
it's
it's a pin it's a word for
it's an emblem for um the relationships
so relationships are the artifact of
whatever the culture is
and so if you can create a container a
space
for people to have great relationships
and you got a really clear north star
you got something and so it's a 30 30 30
30 of the folks
in in your organization or your family
are going to be all about
the first principles and the mission you
know and the purpose they're like yeah
this is i love this place 30 are going
to be like
what are we doing right like this is
just my job man let me go back to work
and you know what you are full of bs
like what are you talking about like
relationships you know and then there's
a middle 30.
that middle third is the swing voters
that's it man so work with them
you know to swing 15 20 of that
you got something special i wrote down
this line from
from the book um that that hit me
which is through relationships we become
and that's another kind of theme that
that underscores all of this so
explain what that means because it
relates to what you just said
yeah i think that it's we're right on it
is that first the relationship
with yourself your relationship with
others
with mother nature through those
relationships you become
the person that hopefully you are
working toward and if you're not
purposeful about it you'll become
something
you'll become someone and if you become
a bit purposeful about it
and you have that you use your
imagination or you calibrate
with your trusted uh community of
mentors or wise men and women and people
that you say
who am i who do i want to become
[ __ ] that's a real question
so through relationships we reveal
we become the person that we are
becoming
and so that's the idea and then uh last
little fun
science note is that harvard did a
really really cool
study do you remember the study at
75-year study
maybe i don't know and they did it on
fulfillment in life
so they tracked people for 75 years and
then basically they wanted to understand
what goes into living a fulfilled life
not cool
so they basically they said okay at the
end of the study did you live a
fulfilled life 75 years
or not and then they drill down
underneath what are those practices
and one of those practices um there's
two really important findings that i i
want to share
one is that those that were fulfilled
wrestled with the deep questions of life
they didn't solve them
but they wrestled what is my purpose
what does it mean to be
alive in modern times how do i work with
money what are we doing here
what happens after life you know what
happens after death i should say
and so those are like really big
challenging grocky
type questions those that wrestled with
them
reported to live a more fulfillment
that's counterintuitive because when i
think of the individual that's wrestling
with those questions i picture the
tortured soul
yes that's the work though that is the
work required
you know like tell me you're not better
because you you
suffer a little bit in your training and
you suffer a little bit in trying to
find the right word to hit
on your um next book or your current
book you know like there's a
there is a little bit of um work and
struggle that goes into it yeah
so yeah and the second one the second
pillar of that finding was
relationships meaningful relationships
for those who are fulfilled
and it doesn't mean that somebody loves
you it means that you have someone
and people to love do you think that
that um
that individual who's wrestling with
these fundamental questions about
what it you know what life is and what
it means
is that teachable or trainable or are
people just
some people hardwired to be you know
prone to that kind of thought process
well i think if um let's be uber
practical if you're
if your thought processes throughout the
day are
how am i gonna eat tonight how am i
gonna feed my kids um
yeah the larger questions are indulgence
that's right indulgences
so once you get that kind of basic stuff
as well secured as you can it doesn't
mean that
this is only for the independently
wealthy that don't need to think about
mortgage that's not me
so you know once you get kind of some
basic frames of
stability and security for safety and
shelter and food and that stuff
you provided the luxury to say okay
what are we doing here because i'm
working my ass off
you know and i'm trying to figure it out
what am i trying to figure out
and i think it's a really important
question to explore and so that's that's
the nature of it
so with this uh um
purpose of trying to get people more
rooted in the present moment
on the front lines of this battle
are these devices which are
scientifically devised to maximize
distraction
to addict us to take us out of the
moment like i feel like
that's where we need to put our
intentional
attention right now if we're going to
win the war
of being present yes
so talk about that a little bit i mean
you open the book talking about that a
little bit and
the work that tristan harris is doing
which i think is super important
and i think this is a really big deal i
don't think anyone would disagree with
that
yeah i think so and i don't want to uh
knock technology at the same level it's
easy for us to kind of pop uh take pot
shots at technology
um i'm not suggesting that's where
you're going but i just want to kind of
say that because i'm about to get
because mike you work with microsoft
[Laughter]
yeah no no but i think that it's doing
uh
it's changing our world and it's really
helping us reimagine
potential and i just want to get a quick
note is that when i grew up surfing
we had to wait a month or two months
before
the magazine would come out with the new
skills that the greats
were doing and so iteration would happen
around that month you know like
the young groms would see it and be like
that look at that you know like that's
what the pioneers are doing
that's what the high performers are
doing and so human potential would
progress
at the rate of um creativity
which is that that it's not creativity
and innovation
is rare it really is but when you can
see somebody else be creative or
innovate
and then it speeds up that thing right
the acceleration of information
dissemination
is related directly to the rate at which
creative expression and innovation can
occur
amen look at your linear logical lawyer
brain
yeah making sense of everything good yes
no i remember that i mean for me it was
swimming world magazine you know
that's right yeah on my bed stand and
you would just count the days until
it was gonna be in the mailbox that's
right and that was the only way of like
knowing what was going on
and now that technology has advanced in
such a rapid rate that you know we're
seeing it daily
we're seeing innovations and creativity
and you know
thin herd potential pushing stuff
happening every day
and so those clips are happening in a
way that almost is overwhelming
and so let's just talk about how our
ancient brain works
in modern times so our ancient brain it
really hasn't evolved
as fast as technology let's be clear
about that
and modern technology they understand
the brain
and the mind so the brain is the
hardware to oversimplify this beautiful
set of
three pounds of tissue that sits on our
skull it's the hardware
and we've got some software let's call
it the mind right now to oversimplify
this
they're better at it than most of us
and so they know how to manipulate the
brain
to be attracted to their technology they
know how to manipulate the mind
to be attracted to their technology
that's their business
and they've got scores of phds
that know how to create dopamine hits
which if you take a lot of dopamine it
would it's called cocaine
so they know how to get the brain primed
for that good stuff
i said good stuff to somebody you know
they've struggled i don't know if
cocaine was a drug of choice for you or
not but
um no i was i was too s i knew i would
like it too much
yeah right yeah so okay so um
so anyways they're better at it than we
are and they're certainly better at it
than a
14 year old is and when i say better is
that as soon as we have some dopamine
and some feel good
stuff on our brain our brain is saying
give me more give me more
and what's required to that is some
breaking mechanisms
some self-control some awareness to pull
away from
the the slow drip of dopamine and
that takes some discernment it takes
some skill it takes some
real grit to do that and it's really
hard to do
if purpose back to that isn't clear
because
it is so immediately a fix uh what's a
word
just attractive it's so immediately
feeding and compelling as a good word
that it's a nice easy trade for that
versus
anxiety versus purpose and certainly if
purpose is not clear
this uh invitation to explore a slow
drip of dopamine is way better
than anxiety depression or this muddled
up purpose
or if my purpose feels like it's just to
work in this system to make somebody
else money the entrepreneur
the owner the factory line worker
whatever so
so um so what do we do i don't have an
answer
well it becomes incumbent upon us to
create healthy boundaries around these
things which takes
a lot of work you know because it is so
alluring
you know i think from a neurological
perspective
what is the long-term impact of
constantly
enduring these dopamine hits like when i
was a kid like a dopamine you know i
wasn't getting dopamine hits throughout
the day
so what happens when you extrapolate
that out over a number of
of decades what does that do to the
human psyche in the human
machine we find ourselves with the
inability to be bored
and that space um boredom is like a
negative connotation to space
and boredom space is the place of create
creative spark and inspiration awareness
insight yes and so
um it's where imagination you know
really can
flourish so i've been bored you know
and it means that i don't really know
what to do with myself in this present
moment
and um i'm struggling to be creative and
and whatever
so we're we're finding i i think that if
you're thinking about your kids for a
moment
is that um there's some cool practices
that we can talk about like
um like my son you know they my son's
school taught him this is that
you don't charge phones and technology
he doesn't have a phone he's 12.
but you don't charge anything in your
bedroom so you charge it out of your
bedroom
um he takes technology breaks all the
time
because he kind of he can recognize the
difference between
um the the freedom to create
in that white boredom space if you will
and how kind of
relaxing and rewarding that is as
opposed to like the stimulating
on button he loves that you're on button
too now so do i
you know so there's there's practices to
be
uh concerned about and at the same time
technologies here it's not going
anywhere so we need we need to have a
relationship with technology too
yeah i just watched my daughters and
this is this is the
vernacular with which they relate to
their peers like they have to be
fluid in this language in order
to fit in and to survive
so it's about where does that tip into
unhealthy
unhealthy relationship or a dependent
relationship well you know when you and
i were growing up if we didn't get
invited to the party
on a friday or saturday night or get
invited to go to wherever
or go on that surf trip for me uh you
find out about it kind of
later yeah not now no it's happening in
real time on snapchat
it's like whoa yeah you know so it's
brutal
yeah it's really brutal there i
there's a this moment where i realized
my philosophy was coming through and
parenting
when um my son was in this small like
he's as old as he now he's 12.
and he was not interested in sport at
this age but he wanted to
kind of play with his friends and it was
a basketball team and some of the other
parents
were um were were like really frustrated
that these eight-year-olds were
losing and i turned to the dad and i was
like this is my philosophy coming out
and i was like
no no this gives him a great chance to
figure out losing too
and he looked at me like you're a loser
gervais like
what do you mean you want to teach your
kids how to lose i was like yeah yeah of
course
yeah i want i want to figure out how to
do that understand
this thing about not keeping score um
i do i think it's you you know why we're
doing it yeah i understand why we're
doing it
but it goes back to what you said
earlier
about the most interesting people some
of your favorite people are the people
who have like
under they've they've they've had pain
in their life they've
grappled with it they've wrestled with
it and they've undergone change like
i know some of the most my favorite
people are all people that
kind of had hard childhoods they got a
lot of struggle
and it's made them you know really
amazing individuals
but how do you square that with your
impulse as a parent to
protect your child and you know immunize
them
from any kind of hardship there's an
athlete that i spent a lot of time with
he was
mvp a couple years i don't think he's
not in the hall of fame but mvp a couple
years and i said hey
how you doing i saw him a couple years
after and i said how you doing
he said great you know like transition
was awesome so good
i said how's your son and he says he's
good
son was like 16. he's good what do you
mean
he says you know mike i gave him
everything
i gave him the best shoes the best
coaches i had him invited to the best
camps
he was on the frickin floor of the nba
kind of ball boy and just around it
he loves basketball but i can't give him
the one thing that i had
the drive and the way he said that was
i had nothing i can't give him nothing
so he goes i don't know if i made a
mistake but
i didn't have cool shoes i didn't have
right coaches
i was left out of the rich kid club
and you know what it taught me i had a
[ __ ] fight
i had to scrap drop my hips figure it
out but when i got on the court
it was on and i had purpose and i had
fill in the blanks of all the stuff
we're talking about
and he knew exactly where he wanted to
go he had a vision of what his future
could be
and he had this incredibly crisp every
day was a mission to get closer to the
to the purpose and the the vision and
goes i can't give him that
and so man that was an attunement moment
for me
like yeah i want my son to have a great
education and this that and the other
yeah i mean that's the the peril of
every
you know uh self-made man success story
right yeah it's that scrappiness that
got them to that place and then
their kids have a totally different
experience
did you ever read the i think it was
called g generational wealth
g1 g2 g3 so g1 are the scrappers
you know bold risk getting after it you
know big vision
type stuff for i'm talking about
generational wealth g2 kind of
hold the line a little bit but don't
really grow it because they're afraid
they were
so close to the the heat of the the g1
and talking about like the vanderbilts
right yeah generation one generation two
you know the sons and daughters in
generation three
they kind of squander it they're like
yeah i'm not close to the fire
happens every time and i got i got 30
million in the bank and i'm
14 million you're 14 years old like what
are you what are we talking about you
know so
yeah that's it's an interesting social
study there
yeah i don't know how you fixed that one
maybe maybe what uh what what's his name
um
nebraska legend one of the wealthiest
people alive uh warren buffett
yeah he's not giving his kids right
hasn't given his kids much
bold well that's a weird one too when
you make that much money and then you're
like well i'm just gonna give it all
away like what is your driving
purpose like what i don't unders i don't
understand
that drive at that level when you're
talking about those kind of numbers
and so there's definitely odd behaviors
in there it's just it's not it's nothing
that interests me
you have to i don't know if it's still
true but if the stock market is up
he gets mcdonald's every day have you
heard this urban i have yeah yeah i
think that's apocryphal
or he and he still lives in the same
house yeah i don't know
i don't know him and i don't know these
but it's a pretty funny story
i know yeah well like so it's not about
money for him but then he's a
you know it's it's a mystery box to me
um one more thing i wanted to explore
with you
you posit the question in compete to
create like what
is there a single determinant of success
right so talk to me a little bit about
that
what's driving success i mean we just
talked about
scrappiness yeah that opens up the door
to
grit and angela duckworth's work and
yeah andrews erickson's work and all
these things that
you explore it's not that simple for me
right that's the question
is there a single determinant and
if we had to hang our hat on something
we'd probably say
you're you're likely not going to ever
kind of
reach your full
expression of who you are as a person
without real work
and so that's where grit hangs here so
grit has three components this is angela
duckworth's
work passion perseverance
for long-term goals so you could replace
i like to replace long-term goals
because they feel so mechanical
to like the vision that you hold for
yourself so
do you have enough passion day in and
day out
and do you have the internal skills so
all of these are internal skills do you
have the internal skills
to roll with the punches to persevere
during the down hard times
and then is the vision clear enough
because if the vision and the purpose
and those
those two words are not crisp and clear
enough the pain will win
when purpose is small pain will win
when purpose is big you'll deal with
some pain and that's the perseverance
piece of this model and so um
we could what we do in the online course
is we double down in the book
we double and triple down and kind of
some of the stuff but to make it simple
there is not one golden thread
for determinants of success but if i was
to hang my hat on something i'd say
grit is really important because it's
got three main components yeah
and so i wish i could find i'm on a
little bit of a pursuit to figure out is
there golden thread that binds
those that explore the reaches of human
potential
i haven't found one yet um yeah and grit
is teachable greatest teeth well each
all three of you should have told
your buddy in the nba about his son i
know
i know you know right yeah it is and so
i feel like it'd be hard to teach though
grit it just feels like
certain people have a motor
you have you have a son like you you
know i've i've got a bunch of kids like
they're all different man and they all
have
their their motors are calibrated
differently and that had nothing to do
with anything
julie or i did and
i think that if when you think about all
three of those it's so mechanical to say
like what we did what's your vision
that's pretty mechanical
requires some honesty and some
imagination and a little accountability
to sharpen it up
so that one's interesting but certainly
goals are relatively easy it's an old
conversation about setting goals
right and when i ask people what do you
think's harder
when i go into a room and there's a
thousand people
and we're teaching about um or even a
small
room with 12 people you know it doesn't
matter like and we're teaching about
grit
and i say what do you think's harder
passion living with passion or
perseverance you know dealing with the
hard stuff
what do you think the room does
perseverance feels harder yeah
my experience has been passion is way
harder
way harder you know perseverance dude
you know it intimately inside and out
most people that are successful
they know how to roll with some stuff
they are resilient
can they get better at it probably you
know that's a skill too resiliency is a
psychological skill
any skill can we can apply some effort
towards we can get better at it
but you can't manufacture passion i
understand
training for perseverance but how do you
train to be
passionate see and i love where you
instantly take it because you're an
examined
serious person is that passion i'm going
to take that i'm an examined serious
person you are you are
i think i'm sorry yeah yeah
you are serious though right i don't
know yeah you're serious i'm serious
you know i don't want to be always
serious but you know anyways so
passion is um there's two things that
get in the way of passion
so consider passion that inner fire
fatigue that'll put a heavy blanket on
passion
and fear so anxiety the chronic
looping worry that things are going to
go wrong
and then the mismanagement of your
energy system
not sleeping right not eating right you
know not moving right
you know that fatigue that chronic
stress the ability to manage chronic
stress
through breathing patterns eating
patterns thinking patterns
that that is the heavy blanket that's
one of the heavy blankets
that sits on the flame of passion and
the other is
you know just worrying like excessive
worry about stuff
passion feels like an unruly
unpredictable
energy source that's hard to control and
hard to direct
oh look at you you go it's big in you
isn't it it's not a little flame for you
huh
well i don't know i i don't really
i don't think about like you hear a lot
about passion you gotta live a
passionate life how to find your passion
it's all about
passion right and now there's this
counter narrative like
that you're seeing where you're being
told
forget about passion that's a fool's
errand it's not about passion that's
like
you know not something you need to be
thinking about
and i sort of sit in this space where
i don't feel like i don't understand
where
passion falls and all of this i
understand drive i understand vision
i understand purpose meaning and all of
those things
but passion just feels like something
that's
floating out in the clouds oh i can't
really wrap my hands around
so if we thought about it this way if we
made it uber concrete which is
um it's just that little fire in your
belly
to go do the thing to climb the hill to
wake up and be about it you know it's
that little fire in the belly that's the
way i think about it
and um
this idea of where the fool's errand is
for passion
is that if you just the passion only
comes from
the special thing that you need to do
it clouds out irrationality it can it
can compel
some bad choices yes it's certain yeah i
wasn't going to go there yes
i fully agree with that and
but the idea is can you live with
passion anywhere you go
can you have a little fire in your belly
in any room that you're in
in any environment that you're in and
that seems pretty daunting
but that's cool like for me i like that
and i'm not saying go chase your passion
i'm saying be passionate and so
where does that uh that hooks around to
me to an
ancient concept this is not something
that i'm to stand on for science
that's the animation of the spirit that
call it a fire in your belly but the
trinity is a really cool
beautiful idea of that many
many um spiritual frames kind of miss
the subtlety
about the animation
of the spirit of the aliveness that
comes with being human
the animation of that magical world that
we don't understand yet and but we think
that there's probably something there
you know call it spirituality so call it
consciousness call it fill in the blank
so man that's what that's all it is for
me i want to be about it
yeah so we all know we all know that
that
that guy or that woman who when they
walk into a room they just light it up
because they they just exude that
in every facet of their life
when i see those people i like marvel at
that because it feels
inaccessible but also i'm jealous like i
want more of that in my life
but then i'm not sure how to cultivate
that i look at it
as a god-given disposition that they
have rather than
something that they developed with
some intentionality oh that's cool i
think there's probably a predisposition
again to that too
but it's definitely something you can
cultivate but the way to cultivate this
is to get the heavy blankets off of it
so it's like a um
addition by subtraction so it's it's
taking those heavy blankets
i i really think that there's a couple
great constrictors
of the human experience right now and
one of those is fatigue
and so examining your recovery
mechanisms in a significant way
mm-hmm i'm not speaking to you rich but
like the pejorative no i i
i need this actually i understand what
you're saying yeah that this is one of
the great constrictors
because chronic stress opens the
floodgate for
draining fuel quotes around fuel
but it just drains organisms
and so if we're not psychologically
skilled to deal with the
chronic stress no different than a dog
you know when an alarm happens for a dog
there's a threat
and they walk away they go to the door
the dormant or the the mailman's at the
door and the dogs barking whatever
and as soon as that threat goes away you
know what the dog does they
roll their head a little bit they roll
their body and shake their tail
and it's like they have just physically
let go
they don't hold resentments we we don't
do that yeah
so yeah i mean which we could it's the
recovery mechanisms that pay dividends
all right we got to wrap this up but
let's close it down with maybe
a couple simple tactics or tools that
people could use that are feeling
overwhelmed they're feeling the anxiety
they're feeling the fear
they're experiencing the vitriol they
can't put the phone down
leave us with some pearls um if i had
pearls you know
yeah pearls i got pearls well i'd say
plenty of pearl necklace
underneath that hoodie the hoodie yeah
i'd say this i'd say
um order one
is um
investigating your recovery mechanisms
let's work in reverse order
take a look at sleep take a look at the
quality
choices you're making around nutrition
and
make sure your hydration is right so
these are all restorative
type of ideas you know like get your
heart rate up in an acute way
if you don't have an underlying
condition like get your heart rate up
where you're stimulating your brain to
say oh
that's right we do hard things and so
i'd say
those are some easy frames to talk about
harder to stay current with
current consistent with and then i'd
also say that
mindfulness is a place to begin and if
mindfulness seems
too unavailable it's as simple as
setting a timer
following an inhale and then an exhale
with all of your might
and starting over every time that you
notice that you're
distracted and the moment that you
notice that you're distracted just
returning back
to the inhale or the exo wherever you
are
[Music]
eight minutes is good science 20 minutes
is a little bit more interesting science
you get to
the ancients would say what are you
doing timing this you know
so um i'd say those are two kind of cool
places to start
and i go way upstream to say start with
something writing down
um your philosophy the guiding
principles in your life
maybe start with your purpose if those
feel daunting
start building relationships when you're
talking about stuff that really matters
to you
and you know for a long time people
would say to me mike
what are the what are the best tools to
invest in
and and this is kind of this
conversation but i'd be remiss if i said
it's a fundamental
organization of your life to be and
become
the man woman or person you want to be
and then the second thing that i missed
for most of my professional life
is the importance of your intimate
relationships
outside of the craft outside of your
business that you're doing
um i wouldn't be the human i am today
without those intimate relations and my
wife at
you know ground zero so um
you know working on being giving love
and giving away as often as you possibly
can
and so it ends up coming back around for
the most part 100
yeah give more love i like it
powerful mike gervais hey man i
appreciate you you're welcome here
anytime
come back and talk to me some more i
always find it
nourishing it's a pleasure to spend time
with you so thank you
thank you if you want to learn more
about
michael check out his podcast finding
mastery
it's uh it is masterful can't recommend
it more highly
um compete to create why is it just a an
audio book how come you didn't do
a print book was it just a deal with
audible or yeah it was an audible
original
so we went in a little bit reverse order
and um
i like the idea of not burning down
trees um
but now i'm craving something tangible
to hold
so we're gonna get to that but that's
not for about a year away
yeah it's cool it's really well done
pete carroll pops in from time to time
yeah thanks man uh to drop some of his
pearls and then i liked how you you
layered in some stuff from your podcast
into it
which is what an audiobook should be
it's a it's a dynamic
uh digital document so cool um
anything else coming up you've got this
like online football
training thing too right 11 on football
or some nice thing you did with nike
football
oh yeah that's uh just you know people
are interested in the mental part of the
game
at scale right now and brands across
the world are really interested in you
know how do we
organize our inner life and train our
minds so it's just a conversation that's
happening
right um i there's a swell happening in
the business world right now
there's an absolute swell not from an
anxiety fixing standpoint type of thing
you know but like hey are people our
most
important part of the company how do we
invest in them
rather than teaching them how to sell
better or market better
how do we help them live better and so
that's
that's the part i'm super excited about
right
cool man all right let's do it again
thanks brother peace
[Music]
you